if you could do anything in the world
what would you do well why can't you do
that then at least start at least try to
make an effort at doing it
I think everybody's afraid to take
chances and do something new in their
life because they're identified a
certain way or they'll be judged if they
don't do it or judged if they do
something different
life is hard it's what you do with it
need motivation watch a top ten of
belief nation what's up at seven my one
word is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have an amazing gift inside
you that I want to see explode out onto
the world so let's get your motivation
to attend and get you believing in you
grab a snack and chew in today's lessons
from a woman who went from being a high
school cheerleader and part-time
babysitter to becoming the most
successful woman in the history of
open-wheel racing
she's Danica Patrick and here's my take
on her top ten rules of success
enjoy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one find your passion
I mean I think the difference between
someone who ultimately is successful and
someone who isn't is just will it
getting up and trying again and I feel
like I've seen that in my life again to
other people is that things get hard and
people try again and things get hard and
people might try again might not and
then things get hard and they just don't
try again and giving up is is is can't
be an option and I think that that goes
back to the core of making sure that
whatever it is you're doing is something
that you love to do something that you
enjoy something that maybe if you didn't
even get paid would you still do it and
I think that's what pulls you through
those times ultimately but and that's
what keeps you coming back for more and
that's what that passion and that love
for what it is that you do is what keeps
you going so would you say your
resilience and that persistence is
because you love what you do so much or
is there something about your parents or
anything in your upbringing you think
it's I mean I think that genetically I
have a deterrent I'm determined because
my dad was very much like that for sure
very persistent and determined but I
think it's also because I found
something that I love to do and there's
plenty of other stuff that I've done
that I didn't keep doing I mean I didn't
keep playing basketball let's face it
but I kept racing and so it was about
finding that I feel and finding it
really young I'm very fortunate that I
found it really young and I I tell
everyone young or old it's just if you
could have if you could do anything in
the world what would you do well why
can't you do that then at least start at
least just try to make an effort at
doing it you're not going to get there
within one shot but but you just got to
take baby steps and opportunities along
the way and I feel like especially like
people get out of college and they have
this idea of what they want to do and
they're holding out until they get it
just get going you know just get working
and get the experience and
and and start working your way there
rule number two is ignore the little man
the first woman driver to lead a lap
under three in a NASCAR Sprint Cup
Series how do you handle it when someone
talks bad about you for the whole world
to hear Shh I say whatever I'm confident
I know what I know you don't ever like
when somebody says something negative
about you but I believe in myself have
to just remember all the things that it
took to get there and
that they weren't easy and then it
allows me to say things like I really
don't care what people say about me rule
number three my personal favorite
start small I mean doing the same thing
I mean just being known for like one
thing your whole life it's a that's sad
you know I there's we all have so many
interests I'm sure and so you know to
get to make jobs of them all or jobs if
you could call it that
but to make businesses out of them all
and see them on a daily basis in your
light and how you visualize them is
really cool and fun and we can all do it
we all can do it so many people are so
afraid to try something because they're
like oh like I can't leave my job
because I'm you know I have to pay bills
or you know it's like we'll start small
then but don't say you can't because as
many times you say you can't you're not
going to if you don't think you can you
won't thoughts become things rule number
four is embrace your uniqueness
so you said what makes you different
makes you great where does that advice
come from that you when you talk to
people well I mean I think that the most
obvious one really obviously is being a
girl um so when I was younger and like
living in England and kind of early teen
years I don't think I I didn't care that
I was a girl I just didn't want to make
it real obvious I mean I didn't want it
to stand out you know I didn't wear nail
polish because when I talk about the
race car I didn't want guy them looking
at my hands and seeing pink fingernails
you know I didn't you know wear pink and
purple and make it really flashy and
obvious no hearts and bows and you know
just kind of wanted to blend in and
having my seven-year-old daughter
am I really parts and bows or didn't
want to wear her she's now rejecting
them but she was all in them so well you
know you go through these phases where
you feel comfortable and sometimes you
don't and I didn't really feel
comfortable making it obvious and so so
it really was I came back from England
when I was 19 and you know I I let
myself kind of go there would be a girl
a little bit and it really came from a
kind of racy photo shoot that I did that
it was more girly of me and it just all
of a sudden it stuff start happening
and people were contacting me and
sponsors and teams and it just but
nobody questioned what I could do you
know it wasn't like people didn't didn't
think I could race or their opinion
really changed on that maybe they had
opinion on what I did but it didn't
change the opportunity to be able to do
what I wanted to do it just really was
opening doors and it was allowing it you
know it was me being able to tap into
something that was part of my
personality I mean I think we were not
one-dimensional people we have all kinds
of different sides to us we're not you
know I don't just race and I don't just
work on cars I you know I race and I
like to cook and I like to travel and I
like to look pretty and I like to get
dressed up and I like hair and makeup
and I like all those other things so it
was kind of a way for me to it was an
extension of me and but it was
celebrated so it came to you as you
embraced who you were exactly so you
know sometimes I really feel that
whatever it is it's the most different
about you is probably the most important
and the most special and the most useful
rule number five just do stuff that
makes you happy now do you think that
you're stepping away from racecar
driving when you deciding it just like
enough is enough
do you think that in some ways that this
is you appreciating other aspects of
life too I don't know there's a lot of
negativity to some degree a lot of grind
it just kind of feels like the grind a
little bit and so I just kind of felt
like it wasn't a space that I wanted to
be in as much anymore like I I want to
be in a happy space where I'm just doing
things that are bring me joy and yeah it
just it wasn't doing that as much or I
was noticing it I was noticing I was
missing that or wanting it more I think
that's really what it comes from is
growing as a person and realizing I
think everybody's afraid to take chances
and do something new in their life
because they're identified a certain way
or they'll be judged if they don't do it
or judged if they do something different
and who are they now and are they crazy
and what are they thinking and you know
it's just life just do things that make
you happy rule number six is push
through hardships I think that what I
took from
film to me that was interesting because
again it's my life and it's been 35
years of just living it's it's kind of
really sucked at times and how hard it's
been I know it's been hard of course but
to be good at anything is hard I mean
I'm sure everybody in this room and
anybody watching is thinks like my
life's been hard too it's true and if
somebody were to put a documentary
together about your life it would
probably be similar and that life is
hard it's what you do with it rule
number seven be a good team player I
mean the team is critical obviously I
mean like you need a you need a bus
driver that you get you got to get a
truck driver to get the car there you've
got to get guys that put the we put the
tires on of course so there's a whole
bunch of steps in the process and it
can't happen without the other but I
think more importantly with team for me
is about morale it's about attitude
it's about your mood and and and keeping
everyone in a good mood like all those
guys that you see right there we see
each other at very weekend of the year
pretty much and so you know that can
wear on you and it can get exhausting
that's the family vacation Emily but you
have that whole yeah so that's my crew
chief on the left he's kind of the other
co team leader with me but you know the
two of us dictate the mood of the entire
team and you really have to you know you
you know being a leader is also being a
cheerleader and it's very important so I
think that you know team is team is a
lot of attitude rule number eight is
take risks doing so well in IndyCar was
there any hesitation at all about moving
to NASCAR because it's very hard to see
from outside how big NASCAR is in the
USA the slight hesitation that I had was
just that when the everything was
evolving with doing NASCAR I was coming
off of my best IndyCar season might
finish lots of top fives I finished
fifth in the championship and it was
like mmm do I really want to like leave
this where it starts again it's like yes
start again and it trust me it's like
way start again more than I thought it
would be
but it's you know it's you know where
the race season was maybe 17 or 18 races
going to 38 so like triple the workload
but man when I first got a stock car I
loved it like I had so much fun the
first time I ever drove it I remember
hearing the the polar opposite of that
be that I remember Dario Franchitti
describing his first time in a stock car
and like he's like what am i doing and
the first time I got in stock car I'm
like I'm home rule number nine is create
positivity I also have a book coming out
at the beginning of the pretty intense
and one of the chapters in the book is
about building your woman cave and it's
full man and I was always written wo
Capital ma n yeah I went to like edits
I'm like why is the man capitalized in
this so it was oh yeah
lowercase n not I'm not trying to not
but it's about a woman yeah anyway um
but it's just something that organically
grew as a space I wanted some space to
do yoga and so it was this pool table
room basically off of the pool and it I
moved some stuff to the side and then I
kind of moved it even more to the side
and then I set my sewing machine on the
ping pong table they got moved to the
side and then all of a sudden I put some
like can I paint it well let's just pick
a paint kind I ended up being the one to
pick the paint color wasn't intending
for it to be my room or my woman cave
and then I was like can I just put some
stuff on the walls I just start
hammering away I didn't measure I just
threw it up very loosey-goosey and
anyway there came the woman cave and I'm
like man everything in this room is
something I love it makes me feel
positive it gives me a space restorative
absolutely it's it's just it's a
positive environment and so you know
yeah it's all about being positive yeah
so your energy to be around
around all the times I mean now I get
why you guys have had man caves for
every all right you've had your like
little zones where you can do what you
love and see what you get your stuff on
the wall memorabilia whatever you're
always have like a room that they
dedicate a special day you live in New
York City you might not have an extra
room you might have quarters so you
might be putting like four different
things in one room in New York City
right you can at least like dedicate a
corner or a spot or something like that
to something so it's just a it's just a
way to create positivity rule number ten
the last one before two very special
bonus clips is tell great stories whoa
what happened oh just a little fender
bender a little fender bender yeah that
tire got a little bit closer to my feet
than intended oh this is the front of
the car that's the front of the car yeah
I hit the wall at about I'm thinking
somewhere around 180 the 160 180 I'm
sure I hit the wall out after I hit the
wall there was fire coming up from
inside of from the middle of the car and
so my hand was on fire and all I was
concerned about was my hair it's an
excellent prop I can't I it takes
forever to grow this batch so I just had
to get out as fast as I could but at
that point in time I was jumping out and
another car had been in the wreck as
well I hit the car next to me Matt
Kenseth and so he actually flipped and
he was still sitting in his car and I
was out of the car kind of headed
towards him he was like telling me to
hurry up and I thought oh my God my car
is gonna blow up something what's what's
going on I turn around looked and kept
going and he said that he just wanted to
make sure that I was coming towards him
away from the racetrack so I didn't get
another twenty thousand dollar fine for
approaching the racing surface because I
did get a fine for twenty thousand
dollars for taking ten steps toward this
towards the track and giving the
universal WTF sign to a driver route
yeah I thought it was good TV but and it
was probably but I still got five twenty
thousand dollars to them
now I've got two very special bonus
clips from Danica on how to create your
own destiny and get the courage to try
something new but before that my
question the day relates to rule number
three which is start small I want to
know what is one small step that you're
going to take today after watching this
video to make a little bit of progress
on that big goal that big vision you
have leave it down the comments below
I'm really curious to find out thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonus clips
I'm a message and something of me moving
forward is how powerful we are all are
as individuals and how you know you know
looking into more reasons as to how I
got to where I am today and even
something simple like I was doing an
interview earlier and they asked about
visualization I'm like I've actually
done visualization since I was in
go-karting like pictured the perfect lap
and so you know trying to figure out
what it is that's got me to this point
and then how to go deeper yeah but you
know we are powerful individuals in and
of ourselves and create our own destiny
and so that's an important message what
I've learned over the years with me is
that trying new things ends up usually
going pretty well and you know that's
where you start to get more confidence
in yourself and and if anything you just
learned something and you have an
experience and life is about experiences
and if something exciting comes your way
just say yes you know just try something
new and not be afraid and the worst
thing you do is fail and you just don't
do it anymore you just dare you try
again so new experiences are how you
grow and I think that that goes back to
the core of like even just living in a
new country when I was 16 I grew up so
fast because I did that and it's about
doing things that are outside of your
comfort zone and something something you
would not do raise your standard Apple
at the core its core values is that that
people with passion and
not one drop of my self-worth depends on
your it's suppose to mean I don't ever
give up I'd have to be dead or
completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten rows of success I have
a very special secret video for you
these are the individual clips that I
have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link the description for
details